it has been and I had to keep fact
checking myself that it has actually
been 10 years since the most traumatic
episode of television in the world and I
think you know what I'm gonna say it's a
little episode called the Red Wedding of
Game of Thrones
geez that was horrible horrible I still
have PTSD from it I don't watch weddings
on HBO I'm taking away weddings from you
can you believe it's been 10 years and
how often is that brought up to you ages
um yeah still fond memories of that
whole experience and and I mean not that
particular scene but the whole
experience I have four memories of it
was kind of you know it's nice to be
back into you know recurring serious
drama where you get so much time to tell
a story and then you get these huge
payoffs like that you know three seasons
deep we got to have this you know
horrible death with characters that
you're invested in I mean I think that's
kind of our ambition here too is to to
create a huge world and get to know
these people well catch
I thought you were gonna catch it they
better not kill off one of you this
season
you get to use some amazing spy gadgets
in the show some fun things if you could
take any of them home make them a
reality which spy gadget would you want
to have
I
I don't you're a hologram I won the
Hologram yeah Richard has this freaking
watch hologram that can just go around
and do stuff for me Daddy didn't make me
yeah he didn't make me very cool gadgets
he got me like a compact that becomes a
grenade like I don't agreement
but the Hologram is amazing stick them
in front of a zoom
I don't know you're not there right you
guys have done a range from like
rom-coms menacing action is there an
itch that you feel like either of you
have not scratched yet that you would
love to do in your career
I mean I have a lot I I feel like in my
Hindi language or Bollywood career I did
many many variety of genres and Bots and
I feel like in my English language work
I want to do a lot more of that drama I
don't know what it is but
um that's something I want to explore a
little bit of on my ear I'd like to do
something in common I know it's nice to
not I mean we go to work every day and
we're like you're gonna die
it's like I've been killed so many times
it's something fun for a minute can I do
something fun I'm putting that out there
something something in the comedy you
heard it here first
foreign